[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu plus
tard un peu plus
tôt par l'avion ou par le métro
ou
simplement en prenant tout son
temps les gens comme nous ne savent
pas ce qui fait avancer leur bas mais on
s'en
va on s'en
va Paris ou pour ton bouou pour Chezelle
ou pour n'importe
où quand on a le cœur à genou la
destination on s'en fout on dit qu'on
s'en fout mais mon
œil chaque remariage est un deuil les
gens comme
nous ils
sont tous
[Musique]
seuls et oui seul tout seul mais pas
plus que ceux qui sont
cocus mais qui se
taisent pour ne
pas pouper en deux la table
l'armoire les deux
cha seul tout seul pas plus que certains
qui
boivent pour oublier qu'ils boivent et
qui tand ils sont à jeun C
[Musique]
lesverognep seul
seul pas plus de ceux qui ont bâti les
cathédrales et qui le
ciel plein des yeux meurent d'une
indigestion
d'étoil seul tout seul pas plus que le
fil de l'homme au pied du
calvaire qui sait que sa mort ne peut
que servir l'orgueil de son
père seul tout seul pas plus que ceux
qui péndgit d'un air très
grave puis qui vont dans d'autrre lieu
se faire souhaitter comme des
esclaves seul tout seulle pas plus que
celle qui monont de neverose en
neverose qui l'hôpital en bordel crèv un
soir d'e Hur d'au
seul vous seul mais pas plus que moi qui
vit ma vie sous des lanternes pour
cacher qu'il y a en moi un cœur gris
comme une caverne seul tout seul tout le
monde est seul tout seul tout seul tout
seul